people in power have always loved slave
labor from actual slaves like during the
Roman Empire to the CF of fatalism to
forcing prisoners to slave away digging
ditches and building roads like in the
Soviet Union all the way to enslaving
people through loans and debts those in
power love slave labor because it's the
closest thing you're going to get to an
infinite money hack you get to literally
create wealth out of nothing for no cost
and luckily today we have a new form of
slavery that is just as powerful why I'm
on social media one reason the art of
Being relevant 100% you never imagine
what it is to watch your video go viral
I stayed off the whole night and watched
it go viral go boom boom boom boom but I
like I was like in Atlantic City or
Vegas with a jackpot like this Bella is
addicted to social media this girl
probably post easy 10 videos a day
that's all she
does this is my time I'm 52 years old
this is my shot you know it's you got
one one shot this is it social media
pays her nothing she doesn't make a dime
when I say I am on my phone always and
let's just get this over with I mean
always I have been on my phone at my
grandmother's funeral where my relatives
like turned around and were just like
put that away but was just a quick text
Brandon cares more about his world
inside of his phone then his friends his
family and going to work many of us
spend more time on social media than we
probably should but for some users sites
like Facebook Twitter and yes Instagram
can become a troubling Obsession causing
them to lose touch with reality I'd sit
in my room for days at a time and just
kind of be there and I had nothing else
to do except for just kind of crawl up
and go on social media vial takes us to
a place where young people are getting
help for their social media addiction
Paradigm says its program which includes
therapy and reconnecting with the
outdoors has an 80% success rate it can
cost upwards of
$50,000 and the great thing about this
new form of slavery is that people love
it the average American happily spends
more than 4 hours a day on their phone
that's at least 10 years of your life
spent staring at a phone screen 10 years
of your life spent laboring away for
these social media and phone companies
while they do not give you a dime in
return today it's no longer about
whipping slaves into action it's about
sending the masses a simple push
notification Facebook's most valuable
asset is how well it knows you every
post you like every page you follow
every friend you make tells Facebook a
bit more about who you are and more
importantly what you buy or who you
might vote for last year Facebook made
98% of its revenue on Advertising that's
$ 39.9 billion advertisers pay for those
personal insights to make sure their
messages reach the Right audience now
obviously Facebook knows what it'sing
users buy when they click on ads from
Facebook but what most people don't
realize is that they have ways of
tracking your offline purchases as well
for many years Facebook has had
Partnerships with data Brokers that
collected information about people's
purchases so for example if you buy a
burrito with your credit card Facebook
could know about that transaction match
it with a credit card that you've added
to Facebook or Facebook messenger and
start showing you ads for indigestion
medicine what started out as an exciting
new invention has devolved into one of
the worst inventions in modern times I
think it's it's funny because I think
there was way less worry about the
democratization of phones and mobile
phones but in my opinion it's it's like
one of the worst thing that could happen
to our civilization you know we're all
stuck on a on a small
screen I am not a BRI thir financial
adviser this video is not Financial
advice and welcome to the new age of
slavery
[Music]
one startup that is trying to turn all
of this around is called M mobile that
the paid sponsor of this video full
disclaimer and the sculpures are on the
screen now but basically mod mobile
built a real phone that you can buy and
Best Buy Walmart and Amazon right now
that pays you cash for using the phone
yes that is right instead of them trying
to siphon and squeeze you for every
penny they can like other companies mold
mobile will pay you for things like
shopping on your phone banking on your
phone or even unlocking your phone
they've already paid out over 100 $50
million in rewards to users and the
average Redeemer earns about $30 to $40
a month we're going to talk about them
more later but the cool thing is that if
you want to invest in mode mobile and
get in on this Paradigm Shift you can
with as little as
$750 by going to invest. mod mobile.com
with the link below early backers are
getting up to 70% bonus shares and
12997 shareholders already participated
in previously sold out allocations so
don't wait claim an exclusive 70% bonus
at 16 cents a share before it sold out
too
as always with any investment you can
lose all your money so do not invest
more than you can afford to lose now
back to the
video at the root of this new form of
slavery is the classic saying the
classic saying is if you're not paying
for the product then you are the product
and the reason why they're able to make
it free is because of advertising
advertising has been around for
centuries you had the newspaper ads of
the 1800s then in 1892 Sears made
history by sending his catalog straight
the thousands of mailboxes across the
country in the world's first Direct Mail
ad campaign and at first these types of
ads were super successful if you were a
farmer living in a small remote town and
an ad for Discount of farming equipment
landed in your mailbox there was a
pretty good chance you would be buying
from the company that sent it to you but
because these ads were so great at
attracting sales it didn't take long for
thousands of businesses to jump on the
bandwagon suddenly newspapers became
almost all ads while mailboxes were
filled to the Brio with junk mail and so
the race was on now if you wanted to
make money from these ads you actually
have to put a lot of effort into them
then radio came about in the 1920s
everyone quickly traded their paper ads
for airtime on popular radio shows and
we will be right back to the 1928 World
Series right after the short commercial
break is just by eating delicious chocy
totsie rolls the same thing had one with
TV in the 1950s and telemarketing in the
80s every time a new form of Technology
came around the amount of people it
could reach would also increase so the
advertisers came flooding in it was the
peak of mass advertising but it still
had its limits in this early form of
mass advertising there was no way for
businesses to choose who they would
advertise to if you were a company
selling farming equipment you just had
to blast out your ads over a large area
and hope that just some of the people
you reach were farmers if your ad reach
100,000 people you could still end up
with only one or two sales it was a
shotgun approach and it was a gamble but
then everything changed with the
invention of the
smartphone this is what iPhone is
okay so we're going to reinvent the
[Music]
phone the iPhone changed everything for
Apple but as Apple you still had a dire
problem on your hands sure you were
making new iPhones every year sure
customers were lining up around the
block for Lum but as soon as someone
bought one of your phones you would stop
earning money from them you would make a
bunch of money once a year during your
launch and then sales would slump it's
still a good business but it could be
better so you started tracking
everything people did on their phones
every app they downloaded everything
they searched for in the Apple app they
downloaded where they live the places
they visited their health information
who their family and friends are all the
Articles they've read online and all the
books music and movies they downloaded
onto their phone all of it is monitored
and sent back to Apple almost
immediately because every action a user
takes indicates something about them if
they downloaded books about farming and
they visited websites about farming uh
that means they're the perfect candidate
for ads about farming equipment and boom
advertising was no longer a shotgun
approach and this changed everything
within a week of someone using one of
your phones you knew more about them
than their Partners parents and probably
even their therapists do and advertisers
ate it up in 2022 Apple made more than
$5 billion from his advertising business
and that number is set to reach at least
30 billion by 2026 and they're not even
the biggest players Android phones
collect double the amount of data as
Apple while Google's operating system
collects 20 times more and yet none of
these companies have to pay anything to
their users in exchange for making them
billions of dollars with this data all
of us are just willfully laboring away
for free and it didn't take long for
social media companies to jump on this
Gold
[Music]
Rush Zuckerberg would you be comfortable
sharing with us the name of the hotel
you stayed in last night uh no as a
social media company you knew just how
big of a gold mine you were sitting on
just by tracking what users did on your
platform you could determine their rate
ethnicity religious and political views
personality traits intelligence
happiness addictive behavior and much
more so you need to make social media as
addictive as possible so you went to the
foremost experts on keeping people's
attention the casinos think about it the
business model of casinos is to keep
people gambling for as long as possible
and to do that they've come up with
attention Engineers so you hired these
attention Engineers to see what
strategies Casino used that you could
Implement on your platforms colorful
emojis special sounds for when a post
gets liked and endless push
notifications to get people to open the
app and these were just the starts
everything from the infinite content
Loop to the pull to refresh feature on
your main feed were all designed to keep
people scrolling and all this attention
just fed the data you had on people to
where you were able to create the
greatest advertising medium to have ever
existed now if you want to run an ad on
Facebook for example you simply go into
Facebook ads and then you're able to
specify the exact type of person you
want to Target everything from age
gender location all the way down to the
most minute of interests and because of
list in 2022 Facebook made a total of
$116 billion from ads $116 billion made
off of the backs of users being glued to
their screen not being paid a single
Cent for it and in that sense this has
become the biggest slave force in the
world and all these Mega corporations
like Facebook want you to think that
this is the only way that if you want to
keep scrolling for free you got to give
up your data for free but what if this
does not have to be the case if your
data is so valuable if these companies
are making billions of dollars off of it
shouldn't they be able to afford to pay
at least a little bit of money for your
data instead of us just slaving away for
free for them well as it turns out this
is definitely
[Music]
possible this is mod mobile M mobile
built a real phone that you can buy in
Best Buy Walmart and Amazon right now
that pays you cash for using the the
phone you can get paid for things like
shopping on your phone baking on your
phone or even just unlocking your phone
and I know it sounds weird but they've
paid off over $150 million and rewards
to users already and users can actually
make a surprising amount of money from
it here's how it works so earn phone is
a phone that you can buy at Walmart or
Best Buy Amazon Etc it's an Android
device and what's unique about it is not
necessarily the phone in itself like you
know Hardware is a pretty commoditized
business at this point right like the
iPhone came out 15 years ago Blackberry
came out 20 plus years years ago and the
first smartphones have been around for a
while so Hardware isn't really changing
all that much right so what
differentiates our phone is really the
software behind itally we've created a
layer on top of Android that allows that
phone to pay you for all these various
activities the way it works essentially
is you have various different categories
that you can earn on it could be things
like reading the news it could be things
like unlocking the phone charging the
phone shopping banking basically
anything that you're going to do across
the various apps we'll reward you for
the time that you spend on Tik Tok the
time that you spend on YouTube we can
basically reward you per minute that you
do those activities for things that we
actually have advertising Partnerships
with it could be a a bigger reward a
smaller reward uh but on average you
know we have some consumers that earn
thousands of dollars you know tens of
thousands of dollars in a given year we
do large sweep Stakes as well so people
win these big uh sweep Stakes but our
average redeemer is probably earning
about 40 bucks 30 40 bucks a month when
they're using our service but Power
users they're earning hundreds thousands
and savings and earnings and thus far
we've been able to facilitate about $150
million in earnings and savings back to
Consumers this is Dan noves he's the
co-founder and CEO of mod mobile and the
cool thing is that if you believe in M
Mobile's Vision to turn the smartphone
industry on its head you can actually
invest into M mobile right now with as
low as $750 by scrolling down and
clicking the link below early backers
are getting up to 70% bonus shares and
12997 shareholders already participated
in previously sold out allocations so
don't wait claim an exclusive 70% bonus
at 16 cents a share before is sold out
too and yes mode mobile users are
earning $1,000 to $110,000 a year right
now as we speak but how how are they
able to make this profitable I guess
when people hear like you getting paid
for certain actions like opening your
phone or watching a video or whatever
how does that model work like how are
you able to do it and why don't these
other social media companies or phone
companies do that the difference between
how we approach it is we try and align
value with the uh consumers align value
with the brands um which are also the
advertisers and that ultimately aligns
value with us and so an example of how
that would work is say you want to play
a game um and you know a company like
Candy Crush they want to people to come
into their app play their game buy and
AD purchases uh so what we'll do is
instead of just saying hey go download
Candy Crush and we'll pay you for the
install uh what we do is essentially we
reward you per minute you play Candy
Crush and then over a s Peri 7day period
of time or a longer period of time you
build a habit and that's ultimately
aligns value with the advertiser it
aligns value with the consumer because
they get a little bit of rewards for
what they do ands because we take a
percentage of that um we're just doing
that across everything and every facet
of your life whether it's you know your
banking shopping working out everything
that you do on a mobile device and the
40 hours that people spend on these
devices and align interest and when you
can do that you can create hundreds
thousands of dollars um you know back
for consumer and in a course of a
lifetime you know it really really adds
up okay so basically if I'm getting this
correctly uh take Candy Crush for
example the example you brought up they
know that if a user spends let's say an
hour on the app they know that on
average they're going to get they're
going to earn like maybe a dollar from
them or something like that so is your
modotto like going to these companies
and saying hey you're you're going to
make a dollar every hour this person is
on the app so if we can get them on the
app can you pay us like 10 cents or
something like that is that correct yeah
I mean every unit economic is different
they have different uh you know kpis of
what they're doing but essentially right
they know that hey if if someone uh
opens up our app x amount of times over
the course of x amount of days uh that
person is more likely to develop a habit
um and so what we'll essentially do is
we'll align to those incentives and
they'll typically only pay us once we
get to that Milestone another example
could be you know with like a Robin Hood
trading account or something where you
know they want people to come in there
open up an account deposit five bucks
and trade and so we all ask them like
how much are you willing to pay for that
and then they'll be like hey 100 bucks
and so we'll take that $100 and we'll
give like say 50 of it back to the
consumer and then now that person has 50
bucks to trade with Robin Hood has a
person that like completed a bank
account did a first trade whatever their
Milestone was and they have a new person
and then we take a percentage for
creating that opportunity amongst
Advertiser and consumer and we'll just
do that across every facet of that
person's Journey on their device but if
it is possible to pay users for the data
like this why doesn't Facebook do it why
doesn't Apple do it why don't any of
these other corporations do it I think
that they don't have the incentive to do
it yeah because fundamentally you know
they have been able I mean everyone's
watched like the social dilemma and
these these these uh movies and like
they have built the dopamine addiction
of the likes and the follows and it's an
addictive thing that people do um so at
the end of the day um unless Regulators
step in which they have in many cases um
or things like the Apple uh you know
privacy ban uh for advertising there is
no reason for why they would need to do
that um if they already have uh that you
know flywheel working so that's why mod
mobile is taking on these Behemoth and
they're not just stopping with their
phone their vision is to get their n OS
onto smartphones all over the world so
that's kind of the thesis behind what
we're working on here with ear phone is
yes we created our own device and our
own smartphone it's for for sale on all
these places but a future that I
Envision is earn phone as a category
where we'll see things like Motorola
earn phone Nokia earn phone Samsung earn
phone and we could power that technology
for those Android manufacturers on those
sub $150 devices which happens to be
about 6 billion devices around the world
and if they're able to continue scaling
like this they're going to be helping a
lot of people today about 1 billion
smartphones are iPhones and the other 6
billion are Android and the vast
majority of people today 6 billion
approximately are earning less than
$112,000 a year which is a pretty crazy
staff 56% of Americans don't have $1,000
their savings right now and so when you
think about that there is a lot of
people that are looking to make a little
bit of extra money and if you can take
that attention and create that you can
unlock hundreds of billions of dollars
back to people and if you can create
that value it's a trillion dollar market
opportunity and that's what we're doing
here and creating earn phone as a
category so that is why they're doing
this public fundraise yeah so the thesis
behind this public fundraise is because
we really wanted to focus on bringing
all of our consumers and turning them
into owners and also opening up to the
retail markets we see as an incredible
way to spread this message around earn
phone we've also priced our shares at 16
cents a share which allows people to
take advantage with a very low minimum
of only 750 bucks and we give a
tremendous amount of bonus shares
depending on when you come in round at
the end of the day what we want to do is
grow community and you know if you
become a mode earner which doesn't take
any cost it's all is free you can still
take advantage and uh be a part of this
movement but if you just want to make a
little extra money on the side you can
pick up their phone right now it's about
99 bucks I the price kind of changes in
that sense but generally anywhere
between $99 to $120 or uh you can go to
mod phone.com we have a subscription
there where you know every year we'll
get you a new earn phone essentially and
you become a part of our earn club which
allows us to unlock other earnings and
savings Beyond just what we can do with
the phone okay wow that's even better so
people can make back their money in just
a few months pretty much yeah usually I
think people that buy our device make it
faster than they can do that and if you
don't want to buy it you can also just
download our product and you uh redeem
your points for it we have a lot of
people that just use a product as an app
user first and redeem for an earn phone
for free with their points everything
will be linked below so stay dangerous
and we'll see you in the next
[Applause]
one